oerlikon mal im sprünge dem wald
richtung
du bist
so was geht ab heute ssk herzlich
willkommen zur ersten runde eskalation
mit texte heute großteils gast und wir
werden heute mal die ganzen hasste sie
überlegungen angestellt hat rauslassen
von apollo nur abraten
und welcher spieler viel besser als rage
mode einfach drauf gibt's ja schon
länger und ich denken kann hat einmal
eine ganze dorf 30 uhr aggressiver ich
glaub nicht wenn es in diesem spiel lag
dann schick ich alles habe ich alles
kaputt dann hab ich alles kurz und klein
ist mir egal man dann rage ich mir keine
ahnung
irgendwas zusammen ok als erstmal hier
erfolg wird direkt mal kein problem für
italien
trefft den bastard einfach nicht aus dem
keller holen sich ihr bestellter und nur
auf naja ich hab mich kaputt gemacht
dass das ok die mutigen nein nein nein
jetzt kommt kommentators push push nicht
neues leg dich du mich scheiße oder was
ja egal jetzt geholt ist das 9
doch was keiner gedemütigt hat einmal es
reicht jetzt die ganze zeit nämlich
kurzfristig dick dekker gegeben
jetzt kommt compper command komm ran
komme merke ich war so dumm stehen da
bin ich denn dumm sie kann nicht kämpfen
nicht gedemütigt und carport kaputt was
los ist eckhard kuhla kalter nebel
ich lag mir mein leben kaputt alter
junge
ich habe einfach mein name ist knappik
mein leben walter mal komm schon ein
bisschen an junge
mit plusgraden bisschen
halte dich fähiger tat ich finde ich
könnte kotzen alter jetzt komm da
verregnete alle weise schießt es kommen
junge komm ran bar gegeben gegeben
wir sterben sterben kollege tony hawkins
sterben alter des todes den habe ich
doch mal locker mit dem puzzle junge ich
ja direkt 2 case allerdings das maß
jetzt demütigen ich will wieder mit dem
mittigen mit effekten die haften
fähigkeiten wurde was war das alter
dieser lady scheiße keine ahnung sind
meine schneeball abging junge band
kollegen ein scheiß kemper alter zu
führen
nein nein nein nein ich scheiße es geht
mir ich kann echt nicht reden und dabei
trocken und nassfutter branche so
höchste konzentration
ja keiner clique alter meine mutter dich
nicht ausschließen sondern löst dreck
und jetzt demütigen nein nein nein nein
nein alter diese feine zwitschern auch
sehr höflich alter macht der denn da so
richtiges unaids vogel ja du größte
alter ist da von hinten besser weiter
oder oder oder oder
nein
ich ziehe mein leben nicht zerlegt mein
leben
ach du scheiße richmond lag heißen
scheiß wieder ist alter nein man gott
gott dort ja meine sprünge demütig du
bist und es wird auch zum dino als
vorlaut wie habe ich dieser bitte nicht
erwischt alter allgäu ist lag zu hartner
der fall
das gleiche spiel ausser steht für 10
sekunden fig mein leben alter jona ich
hoffe drauf ich haue ihn jetzt kollege
was ja erlebt junge an der chamber
skills wieder da einfach neben dem
anschießen okay kein problem
kein problem die kein problem kein
problem nicht
kein problem kein problem ja erwischt du
blöde kuh alter habe ich noch heute
google hatte zugesagt
beleidigungen
was geht alter etwas geht
es geht ihm aber ich lege so harte
schläge so hat hast mein leben rollt
richtung aha du bist du priester mit
ansage mit ansage
da martin face jetzt habt ihr mein
bildschirm bespuckt vorfreude ist das
nicht geil ist das nicht geil
ja und schon wieder erwischt ist mir
egal da ist mir egal
acht läuft nicht nur die letzten kills
drauf alter ist okay ist ich zeige ja
nicht um zu gewinnen ich zocke um leute
richtig fertig zu machen es mir egal ist
mir scheißegal do sul und einer hoch
alter kennt dann erstmal demütigt ecke
der basta junge ist mit dem sohn und
camper hier sollte man das glaub ich hab
ihn nochmal gehalt alter wenn der wende
wenn der fall ich noch was machen wir
dann wer jetzt tot er hätte ja du bist
die kleine [ __ ] alter steigt an
junge menschen eben alles vorbei
knappe scheiße ich hab dich erwischt
hatte man das war intensiv ich würde
sagen wir halten es kurz und knackig wir
sind wieder in der lobby und mache an
dieser stelle schluss wenn ihr mehr
radsport härteren rage sanfteren rage
wenn wir zu viel beleidigt habe schreibt
in die kommentare lasst uns wissen was
ihr hiervon haltet und an dieser stelle
sage ich jetzt macht gute leute
nein macht macht's gut leute ich bin
schon komplett ab und haut rein oder
internet in santa monica mit euch und
machten hieß